[Music]  my name is brian kilmeade been with the  channel since 1996. i loved my job at  fox but i didn't realize the impact fox  was having on the rest of the country i  got a call that sylvester stallone was  doing a boxing exhibition to announce  some promotion downtown growing up i  loved the rocky movies love sylvester  loan would love to have met him and i  got there and it was chaos they quickly  let us know press will not speak to  siloam one on one and i thought well at  least i'll get a chance to see him  within 50 feet and all of a sudden  stallone gets in the ring he bends over  he looks at the press he sees me and he  says hey brian come on over here  [Applause]  and i thought what is he talking about  and he just says what brings you here  you goes oh great because i'm just going  to be boxing a little bit i'll be able  to talk to you after i thought to myself  this is one powerful place it's  resonating with a lot of people it  matters  you